co-host of America reports our very own
John Roberts 4:10 a.m. his time uh John
great work all day I've been watching
you all day thank you for staying up for
us we appreciate it all right tell us
the latest there now Sean it's only nine
o'clock I mean there's nothing to stay
up here but I will tell you Anthony
blinkin burning the midnight oil he gave
that press statement at about 20 minutes
after three just about an hour ago in
which he outlined five broad goals for
President Biden when he comes here on
Wednesday first will be to re irm
America's solidarity with Israel and to
make sure that Israel has what it needs
to defend itself which I assume would
include probably making sure that
Congress appropriates the money to keep
up the stock of missiles for Israel's
Iron Dome and whatever other weapons it
says it might need to keep itself safe
second he wants to coordinate with
Benjamin Netanyahu on the hostage
release there are a number of American
hostages uh I guess Hamas said today
that they've got somewhere between and
250 hostages though they did say that
they would be willing to release all
non-israeli hostages when the conditions
on the ground are right that's one thing
but what about all of the Israeli
hostages and how to get them released as
well uh third and this is very
interesting uh President Biden wants to
hear Israel's military plan and aims and
its plans to go after Hamas in the
northern part of Gaza in a way that
minimizes civilian casualties clearly
even though as you pointed out Sean none
of these neighboring nations want to
take any of the Palestinians who are
trying to flee the violence they're
making an awful lot of noise about it
Egypt's President Ali said to blinkin on
Sunday that he believes that Israel has
gone Way Beyond its right to
self-defense and is now engaged in
Collective punishment of the
Palestinians yet Egypt is not saying
come over the Border we'll take care of
you so what President Biden is going to
try to do is establish uh goals for
humanitarian Aid to probably open up the
ref Crossing in southern Gaza to get Aid
across the border and and even carve out
enclaves where the Palestinian people
can be safe if and when Israel conducts
its military operations in the northern
part now to that end Sean the
president's visit here raises a lot of
questions as to exactly what Israel's
ground operation if it even happens will
look like part of this could be to give
uh Palestinians enough time to get
further south so that they're out of
Harm's Way and then with agreement from
the US president Israel goes in and
turns the place into a parking lot maybe
it's a more limited operation just to
degrade Hamas but Israelis that we've
been talking to for the last few days
say they don't want to play that game of
cat and mouse anymore this time Hamas
has to be gone and then there's the
overarching question of okay if Israel
gets rid of Hamas then what you leave a
power vacuum it's going to be filled by
the next biggest bad guy so there has to
be some plan for either a shortterm
Israeli occup occup ation to keep the
peace or maybe uh fat moves in and
starts to govern gazi as well as the
West Bank there's a lot of moving pieces
to this Sean and we're only beginning to
be able to try to figure out what
exactly will transpire over the hours
and days ahead John if I may a quick
question I I have numerous sources in
Israel I've been there like you many
times before even during conflict not
quite as severe as this obviously and
they're saying that while while Biden is
saying all the right things publicly
that there is a pressure campaign by
behind the scenes that uh quote being
told Israel being told well don't plan
on staying there and Israel's goal is
clear that this area in Gaza with close
with its close geographical proximity to
Gaza uh that it can no longer be a
launching pad for these missiles into
Israeli border cities uh so they feel
like one message is being said publicly
but behind the scenes a very different
message being sent have you heard that
and and we and we saw that contrad
because last week President Biden said
that the United States is fully behind
Israel then last night on 60 Minutes he
said he didn't think it would be a good
idea for Israel to occupy Gaza but again
if you take out Hamas as Israel wants to
something has to fill that void in the
interb while you stand up some sort of
governing body otherwise the Islamic
Jihad or somebody else will move in
there and take the place over but but
every Israeli that I have talked to here
Sean even ones who say they are way on
the left are now saying this has to stop
Hamas has to go they can't keep living
like this a real page was turned in
Jewish history a week ago Saturday and
and the Jewish population is not going
to stand for anything less than getting
rid of Hamas once and for all I think
that is the goal and I think that you're
right I think there is widespread
consensus at on this right now John
Roberts uh please be safe thanks for
staying up uh early in the morning hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else